Медична реформа, яка стартувала торік,
розрахована на три роки і має реалізовуватися у три етапи.
Щоправда, вже нині у впровадженні реформи є затримки.
Перший етап торкнувся первинної ланки медицини і передбачав,
що кожен українець підпише декларацію із сімейним лікарем.
Саме до сімейного лікаря пацієнти мають звертатися насамперед
і, лише отримавши від нього направлення,
звертатися до вузькоспеціалізованих фахівців. Послуги сімейного лікаря безкоштовні.
Головна умова - наявність укладеної декларації.
Нині майже двадцять вісім мільйонів українців уклали такі угоди -
тобто третина населення все ще без декларацій.
У цієї третини вже незабаром можуть виникнути проблеми під час запису на прийом до лікаря.
Адже першорядно обслуговуватимуться ті, хто має договір з лікарем.
Тим, хто не підписав декларації з сімейним лікарем,
доведеться платити за консультацію і медичні послуги.
Без декларації з лікарем нададуть лише невідкладну допомогу.
А якщо, приміром, захворіли на грип, то вже доведеться заплатити за прийом.
А з другої половини цього року звернутися до вузькопрофільних спеціалістів -
таких як лор, невропатолог, хірург тощо -
без направлення сімейного лікаря можна буде лише за гроші.
Підписати декларацію з лікарем можна будь-коли, кінцевого терміну немає.
Національна служба здоров’я радить зробити це якомога швидше.
Програма "Безкоштовна діагностика" мала запрацювати 1 липня цього року.
Однак цього тижня у Нацслужбі здоров’я України повідомили,
що не встигнуть вчасно запустити програму.
Вона передбачає понад п’ятдесят медичних послуг -
від різних аналізів до ренгтену, мамографії, УЗД, скринінгових тестів на рак тощо.
Усе оплачує Нацслужба здоров'я за принципом "гроші за пацієнтом".
Без угоди із сімейним лікарем отримати направлення на безкоштовну діагоностику
буде неможливо.
Причини затримки запуску програми технічні  -
не всі заклади готові вчасно перейти на роботу з електронними системами так швидко.
На запит Deutsche Welle, коли саме українці зможуть скористатися безкоштовною діагностикою,
відповіли, що поки невідомо.
Ще одна ключова зміна з квітня цього року - медикаменти за програмою "Доступні ліки"
видаватимуть за так званими електронними рецептами.
До списку ліків включено 258 лікарських засобів,
64 з яких можна отримати безоплатно, інші ж - з незначною доплатою.
Їх можуть виписати сімейні лікарі, терапевти чи педіатри
через електронну систему охорони здоров’я - ehealth.
Отримати ліки можна в будь-якій аптеці, яка має договір з НСЗУ.
На аптеках-учасницях мають бути налІпки "Тут є доступні ліки".
Механізм наступний - лікар виписує рецепт в електронній системі,
а на телефон пацієнта приходить повідомлення з номером рецепта та кодом,
який потрібно назвати в аптеці.
Якщо у пацієнта немає телефону, лікар може роздрукувати код.
З квітня лікарі вже виписали більше одного мільйона електроних рецептів.
Утім, іноді в приватних аптеках виникають проблеми з видачею ліків за електронними рецептами
через те, що їхнє програмне забезпечення потребує оновлення
і ще не під'єднане до електронної системи охорони здоров'я.